we have the hardest minecraft parkour
map in existence and the first person to
finish this map wins ten
thousand dollars chris are you ready to
ruin some dreams
let's ruin some dreams are you ready to
make kids cry
crying crying take that as a yes if
that's the case then drop the gate and
begin the parkour challenge give me
permission to mess with people
mess with them they don't even realize
10 grand is on the left oh someone
already made it all right i'm going to
go let them know that 10 grand online
contestants the challenge has begun
first person to the end gets ten
thousand dollars that's a lot of damage
okay good luck everybody i literally
made a path for this guy and he freaking
fell in the lava
oh who did that i leave our call for 10
seconds and you do this
they got to make the jump though why
he's not even going forward
finding the best path carl it's all it's
all about the puzzle
oh poor guy oh no jimmy you're a monster
and you might be wondering why is carl
not playing on his carl account the
reason is one of our friends tags who
lost the island because he wasn't
subscribed to pewdiepie
he's in town and we want to try him out
on the gaming channel be nice to our boy
yeah
chris stop i'm helping you for the love
of god
i've been helping him carl i'm a monster
call me usain
though a lot of people are still
attempting the first course server open
up the second game oh no
no i'm not ready and now they're going
oh my gosh chris what is this watch this
it's a trap see how they're all on it
right now yep
if you're gonna cheat you get in the
lava it's fair
oh my goodness
i get screwed oh come on you can hear
carl screaming
welcome to the gaming channel tags no
first he lost an eight hundred thousand
dollar island and now he's about to lose
10 grand here i tried so hard
who's this guy chris stop building the
road i just like doing it watch watch
watch
he's so happy you screwed calendars the
same guy chandler just screwed
now that we screwed calendars and tags
drop the third gate oh the ice map
wow they already beat it jimmy what are
we doing did they actually already beat
it yeah some people already on this oh
my god they're so sweaty
don't worry it gets much harder all
right
go go go oh not you all right this guy
looks to be killing it i feel like his
dream in disguise cherry bomb man can
you add him to the call what up cherry
how's it going hey how are you doing
good all right that was all you can
leave
oh i can't hit you all right drop the
third game oh
this one looks really hard you're
literally about to get a nuke
tactical nuke inbound
it's so funny just watching them
disappear all right let's not mess this
guy let's see if he can do it go go go
go he's scared back away back away
he's taking too long oh my god
play a montage of people disappearing
with sad music i bet it's hilarious
you can't make that jump can you you got
this let's go
all day baby all day all day all day
baby
come on jt money jt money it's his money
and he wants it now
oh yo chris why do you look like a
monster i don't know why do i look like
a monster because monster legends is
sponsoring this video remember how they
gave us a monster last time we collabed
with them
they did it again i don't know if i
could handle another monster
it is a free-to-play app available on
ios and android yeah
it's a strategy game where you feed and
trade your monsters to take them into
battle there are hundreds of different
monsters you can collect
look at all the different variables and
if you want to be more unique you can
grab one and grab one and make your own
hybrid monster
here's how you can get the new mr beast
monster by purchasing him directly on
the legends pass which includes
other awesome rewards available from
september 18th to september 27th now
let's tell them the four different ways
they can get the other mr beast monster
completing daily in-game goals
participating in the mr beast breeding
event
or by collecting the cells for free on
monster wood if you collect all the mr
beast undead related monsters you get
extra rewards
why if any of this interests you you can
download muscular legends using the link
in description thank you so much for
sponsoring this video get our new
monster and let's go back to gaming
all right open the fifth or sixth
seventh gateway for los angeles despite
having a ton of people competing only
three are on this actually i think
one fell only two people are on this
part of the map
they're not trusted oh i got him you got
me
i'm gonna build a secret tunnel over
here secret tunnel
secretary how is tax doing so far is he
still really sad he lost the island oh
you lost the island
as well i lost it i also lost the island
hey
i gave away the island which means i
also lost it
there's a hole right there they can't
find it
i don't know one person finds it and
then the horde just kills totality jimmy
they just keep
on falling for it every
some people are starting to catch up
open the next gate server
if you do oh my goodness what hole right
there hold on hold up
what isn't that kind of beautiful yeah
it reminds me of a certain
watery place that we were i swear to god
this calendar guy has to be dreamer
techno he probably thinks he won
but this isn't the end once you go
through that portal you're gonna be
teleported here one at a time
based in the order you went through the
portal this is the final part of the
obstacle course and it is insanely hard
but the first person
to get here wins ten thousand dollars
tags you can do it
calendar is the first person to get to
attempt it oh my god oh
all right um wait um wait is he about to
win the 10 grand what
already no way it took me like five
tries to get the first job
oh you're do you
hate money jerry you made it to the last
part
of the obstacle course if you complete
this you win ten thousand dollars and no
one else is allowed to go until you die
so all the pressure's on you you know
that car you need
or whatever that thing is that you need
my debt yeah you know that debt yeah
make a couple jumps right here
and it's gone all right first jump
second jump
all right oh he's made it to the chain
oh he's right here
he's standing on my head boom boom okay
this is the part oh
he rushed it i'll be right back all
right see you in a minute cherry you can
attempt it as many times as you want
look at me go whoop tags is here
let's do this will he land the ladder
stall done
well he's stomp on my head done okay
yo cherry bomb man's back yeah speed see
those people there watching
yeah that's like five people 10 million
people are gonna be watching on youtube
up tags hey what is going on tags this
is the final stretch of the map and if
you complete it you win 10 grand
are you about to win the first minecraft
video you ever competed in i don't see
why not
tag tanks you can do it let's go already
i'm going to start breaking the ground
below you oh god don't shift
okay
it's taking much longer than i thought
for someone to complete this so
instead of going one at a time we're
just gonna let him go all at once boom
all right now they can all attempt it at
the same time oh he's speeding he's
speeding
they're all just chilling here oh you
can do it
they're like look at all these people
literally ten
thousand dollars is on the line in any
of these players could win it so right
now
kenneth is in first place he's going all
out cherry bomb
oh but jerry has passed him do you guys
not want 10 grand go go
go he's so much better than any of us
could ever be all right i'm gonna
attempt this
i'm going to call dream and see if he
can beat this your call has been
forwarded look at this old man doing
parkour oh man
oh man skills you got it oh you don't
got it hey
so techno we're filming a video and it's
another parkour video and no one's able
to
complete this parkour map do you want to
hop on and see if you can do it i'm
willing to try
technoblade is here let's see if you can
make this jump techno
oh we've had like 100 people attempting
this course for like an hour this is a
pog moment
and he was so close why is it literally
only that guy that keeps getting to the
end would you eat for breakfast
technically some subway sandwiches
for breakfast i'm gonna join the discord
with all the contestants i'm trying to
give one of y'all ten
thousand dollars i'm begging you someone
take 10 grand from it
well if you want to take it just
complete the map all right let's see if
techno can do it
oh this is pain oh oh
no we made the back part of the map
easier so now
people are just flooding in all right
someone has to win 10 grand
this is going to be even harder now
because there's going to be a thousand
people standing on one block come on
terry
jam despite literally having them spawn
here and
thousands of attempts no one has
finished this yet
i wasn't lying at the beginning of video
and i said this is the hardest parkour
map
ever oh wait oh he's on the side oh
oh what he made the jump and then walked
off
yo add cherry bomb in the call i had
cherry bomb in the hall don't talk to me
literally don't talk to me i'm so mad i
don't i don't want to be alive anymore
i literally just want to fall off the
space of the earth right now well you
did
you literally made the joke i was like
you know what ten thousand dollars
sounds nice but you know what sounds
better
falling off the side of the map cherry
cherry if it makes you feel better i'll
play the clip again in slow-mo that was
beautiful he literally just took ten
grand and lit it on fire
finish the map you got this oh swedish
dude's here
let's go crypto oh he played it oh he
made it
oh he made it congratulations
you came in second place and you won
five hundred dollars oh wait second babe
who wants
one that you know that guy with the
bacon head oh did he actually win
no he didn't you just won ten thousand
dollars
i'm shaking congratulations that was all
thank you for watching hit the subscribe
button see you in the next video